I think people are never going to stop
traveling
um so I think it's more important to
actually really consider how you're
traveling what businesses you're
supporting when you travel because I
think you can actually make a much
bigger impact by being more intentional
and selective about how you're actually
going to impact the destination on on
these decisions you make being green or
Eco is doing no harm sustainability is
reaching that neutral but actually for
generating and restoring and
replenishing a destination or Community
or ecosystem is going beyond that
threshold of just sustaining simply
sustaining something that's really just
not about the ecosystem and
environmental aspect because all all
environmental and climate change issues
are as a result of people's I think it's
coming with the mentality of wanting to
learn and also honor the sense of place
that you're going to so at the end of
the day it really comes down to the
people